d'ici la fin du quinquennat plus
personne ne paiera la taxe d'habitation
sans augmentation d'impôts a martelé le
président de la république
depuis cette annonce non concertée les
élus attendent vos propositions
le dégrèvement étant pour l'heure
financé par du déficit et donc de la
dette en octobre ont balancé son maire
avec mépris quelques semaines plus tard
les élus de proximité des devenu le
rempart de notre démocratie un pilier
sur lequel le gouvernement souhaitait
s'appuyer
alors que les communes aujourd'hui vote
leur budget et à moins d'un an des
municipal les élus ont besoin de
lisibilité de stabilité de confiance sur
l'évolution de leurs ressources pour
programmer leurs projets la chose est
d'autant moins aisée que les annonces
ont précédée la réflexion sur la
fiscalité et le financement des
collectivités qu'en novembre la fronde
de nos concitoyens conduit le
gouvernement à prendre 10 milliards de
mesures d'urgence sans compter celles à
venir obérant quelque peu vos
projections financières
on sait ce qu'il advint de la fiscalité
écologique qui devait venir au secours
du financement du dégrèvement
le ministe de l'action et des comptes
publics indique à l'assemblée nationale
la suppression de la taxe d'habitation
pour tous et confirmer hors résidences
secondaires quid des logements vacants
et des bases locatives
la taxe sera compensée à 100% mais
comment dégrèvement compensation
remplacement c'est flou sans doute dans
la loi de finances pour 2020 mais c'est
aussi flou en revanche ce qui est clair
c'est qu'à compter de 2020 le coût pour
l'état de l'ensemble des dégrèvements
devrait s'élever à plus de 20 milliards
d'euros par an ma question est simple
comment envisagez-vous financer votre
réforme dans le respect de la libre
administration des collectivités puisque
aucune de vos hypothèses émises jusqu'à
l'orne a tenu la corde pour conclure
monsieur le premier ministre je serai
bien les propos de notre président
gérard larcher
on ne redressera pas notre pays sans les
élus et les territoires ne l'oublié pas
merci
la parole est au secrétaire d'état
auprès du ministre de l'action des
comptes publics sur du som monsieur le
ministre mais la parole merci monsieur
le président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur luron
merci votre question qui porte sur un
sujet important
la réforme de la taxe d'habitation
réforme qui a été annoncé par le
président de la république lorsqu'il
était candidat réforme à laquelle ils
s'étaient engagés et que nous menons
c'est un sujet qui est important car la
taxe d'habitation est à la fois une
ressource substantielle des
collectivités et sa suppression est une
manière de rendre une part tout aussi
substantiel de pouvoir d'achat à
l'ensemble des contribuables français
en réponse à votre question je souhaite
apporter trois précisions la propre et
la première pour vous confirmer que
d'ici 2022 nous souhaitons effectivement
supprimer la taxe d'habitation pour
l'ensemble des résidences principales et
non pour les résidents secondaires comme
nous l'avons dit depuis le début de
cette réforme et nous veillerons à ce
que l'intégralité des recettes perçues
par les collectivités communes et
intercommunalités soit compensé la
deuxième précision que je veux apporter
devant vous tient au calendrier de mise
en oeuvre de cette réforme
l'intensité des concertations parfois
même il faut le dire les divergences
d'approché de tel ou tel ce tract de
collectivités territoriales quant au
remplacement la taxe d'habitation pour
les collectivités concernées nous
amèneront avec jacqueline gourault
sébastien lecornu et gérald darmanin à
rouvrir dans les prochains temps une
concertation avec les associations
d'élus les représentons et les
parlementaires
l'idéal aurait évidemment été
d'envisager un projet de loi de finances
rectificative au moment de l'été 2010 9
en réalité et vu l'intensité de ces
relations nous sommes plus raisonnable
et je pense que nous aurons à traiter
cette question à l'occasion de l'examen
du plf pour 2020 est ainsi l'ensemble
des candidats et des candidates aux
élections municipales seront dans quel
cadre financier ils pourront inscrire
leurs actions et comment ils pourront
mener et élaborer leurs programmes c'est
une réforme qui est importante monsieur
le sénateur vous le savez est là des
enjeux qui sont majeurs et nous
travaillerons à la compensation des
recettes pour les collectivités sans
créer d'impôts nouveaux
en dégageant les économistes nécessaire
et fidèle à l'engagement du président de
la république de donner aux communes et
aux intercommunalités et plus largement
à toutes les collectivités territoriales
des ressources qu'ils soient justes qui
soient pérennes et qu'il soit durable